[Música]
hoy analizamos el origen de los pueblos
eslavos cuando que es la capital de
ucrania en el centro del primer estado
eslavo creado por el grupo de
escandinavos que se hacían llamar rus
ese gran estado medieval fue el origen
tanto el ucrania como de rusia según
varios historiadores la parte occidental
de ucrania ha tenido una historia muy
diferente a la del oriente
adelantándonos un poco al origen de este
pueblo ahora en conflicto en 1997 luego
del colapso de la unión soviética un
tratado entre rusia y ucrania dibujó y
asegura la integridad de la cuestión
ahora las fronteras ucranianas sin
embargo hay contrastes a cada lado del
río dniéper al oriente de los lazos con
moscú son más fuertes y su población
está en su mayoría más
ortodoxa y también habla ruso y al
occidente sus habitantes son más
católicos y hablan su propia lengua el
ucraniano saludamos entonces a isidro
sepúlveda profesor de historia
contemporánea de la universidad nacional
de educación a distancia en españa'
analista internacional y especialista en
geopolítica
gracias a profesor por estar nuevamente
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 y vamos a empezar por el
principio como dicen los españoles para
el origen de estos históricos o pueblos
rusia y ucrania hablemos de los pueblos
eslavos
bueno en realidad no
hay un origen de un pueblo hay distintas
tribus que provenían de las estepas de
siberia lo que se conoció con las las
hordas de oro y que van a colonizar
sucesivamente durante siglos a lo largo
de prácticamente un milenio van a van a
colonizar no solamente las estepas del
este de europa sino que van a entrar en
profundidad en el en el conjunto de
europa
en lo que hoy sería ucrania y
prácticamente la la rusia europea al
lado este de los urales se van a sentar
distintas de distintas tribus que van a
enlazar de una forma bastante
indirecta con tribus que van desde lo
que hoy es finlandia hasta lo que en
realidad son las orillas del mar de el
mar negro cuando en crimea también se
asientan unas tribus tártaras que
contrastan por primera vez con las que
hay en el norte la primera entidad
política como ha dicho anteriormente es
el rush de kiev que aproximadamente en
el año de 882 ya existe como tal que va
a ir evolucionando hasta conformar la
entidad política más importante de la
europa de ese momento incluso el imperio
de carlomagno el imperio el primer
origen del imperio romano-germánico con
los
los botones primero el botón tercero
ésta está
vinculado con
es menor y está vinculado de una forma
diplomática y con un reconocimiento de
vasallaje al rus lakers posteriormente
esto va a ir evolucionando en los siglos
fundamentalmente 14 y 16 hasta que
definitivamente se crea como a los
reinos de router ya eso estamos hablando
entonces qué son los orígenes del gran
estado medio al profesor
si esos son los orígenes de un estado
medieval del cual surge la ucrania
moderna pero también es el origen de lo
que posteriormente va a ser el gran
ducado de moscú el gran ducado de moscú
va a ser una desagregación del el rush
de kiev es decir a antes de que exista
rusia de que existan los orígenes de
rusia ya existen cuatro siglos cuatro
siglos antes existe los orígenes de
ucrania
profesor ya yéndonos yéndonos mucho más
al futuro no casi que a la actualidad
como fue el proceso de independencia de
ucrania tras la disolución de la unión
soviética
es importante señalar el hecho de que
esa es la segunda independencia la
primera independencia se produce en
concomitancia con la revolución rusa con
el estallido de la revolución
bolchevique y en
1918 como tal
ucrania tiene su independencia no
solamente obtiene obtiene su
independencia
ha sido segregada con el tratado de
presley todo y ha estado en posesión
durante muy poco tiempo del imperio
alemán y cuando el imperio alemán
claudica pide el armisticio y luego se
firman los tratados de los tratados de
parís y ucrania como tales
independientes estamos hablando de 1918
y de hecho ucrania va a ser se va a
consolidar como una va a participar de
la revolución soviética
y se va a crear la república socialista
de ucrania que junto con la de rusia y
bielorrusia van a fundar la unión
soviética la unión de repúblicas
socialistas soviéticas
justo ahora un siglo en 1922
posteriormente con la implosión de la de
este gran estado que fue la unión la
unión soviética
1991 es el acto de reconocimiento
de la independencia de rusia bielorrusia
y ucrania lo que de ory da origen de
facto al acta de defunción de la ex
profesor ya para ir finalizando nuestra
conversación porque nos queda poco
tiempo muy encantado preguntarle
muchísimas cosas y ahondar más sobre
esto que es muy interesante porque el
presidente actual de rusia vladimir
putin le cuesta tanto reconocer entonces
esta independencia de ucrania y mire las
consecuencias que estamos viendo en la
actualidad por dos razones fundamentales
una porque útil está reescribiendo su
historia está reescribiendo el relato de
la conformación del imperio del imperio
ruso y trata de recuperar las fronteras
de
1917 y por otro por ahora pura propia
propaganda lo que hace fundamentalmente
es deslegitimar incluso la propia
existencia de un estado de un de un
pueblo de un país que se llama ucrania y
que incluso como estábamos conversando
lo vino antes de rusia profesor
muchísimas gracias
por analizar un poco estos orígenes
históricos de estos dos países estas dos
naciones